your parents were like supported from
the beginning yeah they've always been
support they always come to shows and
stuff I mean you know they don't always
say what I'd like them to say
emotionally but they came to the show
they weren't like you can't do you're
never gonna make it you piece of
like my parents have always been
supportive and always have been like you
can do this you could do that but they
don't like the my mom is always like are
you just not curse like that I remember
Chris Rock saying once he was like when
my mom's at a show I just don't curse in
front of her oh wow and I was like what
and and like but it's I I'm like come on
guys like is that what we're talking
about here I like the idea of Chris
Rock's mom's in the crowd and he's like
there's black people and there's other
black people
there's this other set of black people
that don't behave as well as in yeah
he's like my mom's here I'm sorry I
gotta